I'm Adam from PlayStation grenade
welcome to story time today we are
looking back at dishonored in three
minutes or less so let's do this in
Dishonored you play as corvo attano who
is returning from a trip to find a cure
for a deadly plague that is ravishing
the city of done well Corvo is the
protector of Jessamine cold wind and her
daughter Emily who essentially are the
royal family in this story the second
you arrive to resume your duties you are
attacked and restrained by a sinister
group led by a man named dot you watch
Jessamine die and emily is kidnapped
leaving Corvo to take the fall for cold
winds assassination six months later
Corvo is in prison awaiting execution
but not before he is told the identity
of the man who planned the murder and
framed Corvo harem burrows the former
royal spy master is now the Lord Regent
just in the nick of time Corvo escapes
his jail cell and finds a man named
Samuel who takes him to meet Admiral
Havelock who is the leader of the
resistance against the new Lord Regent
Corvo decides to go for a quick nap and
whilst dreaming he meets a guy called
the outsider who's a god-like being who
brands him this mac gives him
superpowers like the power to call on
rats to dispose of his enemies and have
cost the usual bending time to fit his
will Carville then goes on a murder
mission taking out the high oversee and
other conspirators who have helped
assassinate Jessamine he then finds
Emily in a brothel and saves her just
before she is introduced to a different
way of life returning to the resistance
headquarters aka the pub Emily begins to
train with Calysta in the hope that one
day she will become the Empress just
like her mother once was the final two
names on corvo's murder list are the
financier of the Lord Regent lady boil
and of course the new Lord Regent
himself who goes down without much of a
fight
carve all goes back to the pub to
celebrate all his murders and have a
drink with the boys sadly his drink is
spiked with a deadly toxin luckily for
Carver Samuel the ferryman from earlier
likes him so he only gave him enough to
look like he was dead called a
non-lethal dose they say his prophet
whilst working Corvo discovers it was
his own allies who attempted to kill him
have a lot now acts as the Emperor have
done well by controlling Emily so Corvo
adds extra names to his kill list cobol
finally catches up with Jessamine's
killer Dodd and murders him promptly
after a long battle to reach have a lock
combo killed him too and saves Emily
unless you play a different way around
where they both died bird onto that
boogie man everyone lives happily and we
all forget about the plague ravishing
the city below us the game ends with the
mannequin challenge and an uncertain
future which will be picked up in
Dishonored 2 like who the heck is
Emily's father I think that one's a bit
obvious but I won't spoil it anyway
thanks for watching please subscribe for
more videos like this one and help our
tiny channel grow i'm adam from
playstation grenade see you next time